est-ce que vous pensez que j'aurais pas
pu faire comme temps avant moi mettre la
poussière sous le tapis oui
salut ce 22 mars Emmanuel Macron a eu
une interview sur TF1 pour parler de la
réforme des retraites du 49-3 de la
colère grandissante dans le pays etc
vous avez été plus que nombreux à me
demander une analyse non verbale de ça
c'est ce que je vais faire aujourd'hui
attention je répète quand même les bases
je ne fais pas une analyse rhétorique
par exemple il y a d'autres personnes
qui le font très très bien comme Clément
par exemple je fais pas une analyse
politique parce que je m'y connais pas
assez mon seul taf ma seule préparation
c'est de faire une analyse des réactions
non verbales d'Emmanuel Macron face aux
questions qu'on lui pose et à ce qui
répond donc je délie en fait le fond de
la forme je reste sur la forme même si
je prends aussi un petit peu de
paraverbal il faut que je mets plusieurs
quelques mots quelques intonations quand
même clause de nom responsabilité qu'on
peut remplacer par disclamer n'oubliez
pas que ce que je fais c'est une analyse
de mentaliste ça veut dire que ça
s'apparente presque à une analyse de
comptoir ne prenez pas ça pour argent
comptant c'est ma propre analyse à moi
ça ne vaut que pour moi je vais piocher
dans des dans des sentiments dans des
trucs que je connais qui sont
scientifiques ou qui sont complètement
pseudo scientifique bullshit ça donne
cette analyse que vous allez voir le
seul but est de partager ça avec vous
mais n'en faites pas une vérité et ne
coupez pas ce petit bout de passage que
je donne quand vous prenez des extraits
de ma vidéo voilà merci beaucoup et si
témoin ça fait plaisir c'est parti pour
l'analyse vous excuserez le décorum je
suis actuellement en tournée pour mon
spectacle de mentalisme en Suisse je
suis à Morges donc je le fais depuis la
chambre d'hôtel et je vais tout envoyer
à Loïc pour qu'on sorte ça rapidement
bonjour monsieur le Président vous savez
que votre parole aujourd'hui est
particulièrement attendue c'est la toute
première fois que vous vous exprimez
depuis le recours au 49.3 et depuis que
cette réforme des retraites a été
adoptée par le Parlement elle est très
contestée dans la rue première question
donc est-ce que ce texte entrera en
application comme prévu au premier
septembre bonjour et alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut déjà voir de toute cette
introduction c'est intéressant il a le
bras gauche la main posée sur le bras
gauche il bloque sa gestuelle il s'est
déjà qui va être regardé qui va falloir
qu'il se contrôle il a la bouche un peu
sèche il s'humidifie les lèvres pendant
que la journaliste lui commence à lui
poser la première question et au moment
de commencer à attaquer de répondre on a
un vrai mouvement vers l'avant avec la
tête qui se penche donc le mouvement de
l'attaque en fait de ok c'est parti je
suis sur le ring et la tête qui se
penche alors la tête qui se penche vers
l'avant on dit qu'en général c'est c'est
une forme de honte ou de d'avoir quelque
chose à cacher je pense que là plus
simplement il se recentre à ce moment là
peu en effet on commence à décaler l'âge
légal de trois mois par an
progressivement et qu'on accélère les
l'augmentation du nombre de trimestres à
travailler jusqu'à 43 ans à horizon 2027
et bien il faut que ça rentre en vigueur
d'ici à la fin de l'année mais
maintenant au moment où je vous parle
c'est marrant parce que dans son
paraphrase dans ce qu'on appelle la
prosodie c'est-à-dire la manière de
parler des voix etc ça fait deux fois
l'un deux minutes 30 2 3 fois que
j'entends des vieux Rolands de prosody
de Nicolas Sarkozy alors je sais pas
pourquoi est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est la dose de stress est-ce que c'est
le sentiment de d'être tout-puissant au
front les hypothèses on sait pas qui ce
qui va le relier à Nicolas Sarkozy mais
on a eu deux trois trucs il y en a eu
juste avant deux minutes je vais te le
remettre c'est un tout petit bout de
truc vers une 54 Loïc jusqu'à 43 ans à
2027 et bien il faut que ça rentre en
vigueur d'ici à la fin de l'année mais
maintenant vous avez entendu le même
maintenant mais maintenant parce que tu
étais Monica Sarkozy je l'ai incroyable
et on a on commence aussi à avoir des
mouvements nerveux ces mouvements
d'épaule pour évacuer une forme de
stress et de contrôle parce que quand on
se contrôle trop qu'on contrôle trop son
corps ce qu'on envoie dans ces
intonations dans son visage dans sa
gestuelle à un moment donné on est sous
tension permanence donc il faut que le
corps évacue d'une manière ou d'une
autre vérifier cela parce que j'ai des
choses hier précises à des
parlementaires qui ont subi des
agressions elle a aussi à des
parlementaires on retrouve les
intonations à l'ancienne c'est
incroyable non pas du tout et merci de
me permettre de clarifier cela parce que
j'ai des choses hier précises à des
parlementaires à 23 on voit aussi qu'il
a les jambes croisées ça veut dire qu'au
début de l'émission il avait jambes
croisées et main bras droit sur bras
gauche donc on est quand même en full
verrouillage et full control full
verrouillage ça veut dire rien ne rentre
et c'est moi qui fait sortir des choses
en terme de métaphore sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est très fort
quelque part ajouter une petite like là
je suis un peu ah si ça va être un peu
mieux de ces manifestations et
d'intégrer une partie de ces on y
reviendra vous convient à côté de ça non
à côté de ça je vous le dis dans le
moment que vivent nos démocrates quand
des groupes utilisent l'extrême violence
pour agresser des élus de la République
qu'ils soient à 3,14 de la vidéo ça
tombe bien ses pieds moi ça me parle on
reprend la gestuelle du décompte alors
ça c'est ça c'est une manière
d'argumenter corporelle on allait sur
cils lever on a le truc comme ça de
voilà il y a pas le choix c'est une
démonstration mathématique donc on ne
peut pas la critiquer c'est pour ça que
le corps est tellement en avant avec le
bras qui est posé et là on y va c'est un
peu comme si on envoyait des bases à ce
moment-là alors que précédemment il
était plus dans l'encerclage c'est à
dire nous moi le gouvernement c'est
notre truc à nous et les seuls moments
où l'ouvrez c'était pour faire des
gestes de on avance pour avancer faut
avancer dire que quand il ouvre c'est
soit pour repousser en fait avec ses
mains c'est encore une fois c'est de la
symbolique soit pour repousser avec ses
mains et pour dire de toute manière faut
que ça avance soit pour protéger en fait
l'enceinte du château et là maintenant
qu'il a cassé ça c'est juste parce qu'il
est en position d'attaque donc on pose
en soutien le bras sur la table et on
envoie les cartouches
en aujourd'hui ou mère malheureusement
chaque semaine quand ils utilisent la
violence ça c'est un peu marrant je le
mets quand même à trois vins Loïc parce
que donc ils fonctionnent souvent par
triptyque Emmanuel Macron dire que quand
il veut essayer d'argumenter quelque
chose ou de convaincre il a il a ses
trois points il les envoie avec ses
doigts je l'ai vu dans plein d'analyses
que j'ai pu faire précédemment et
souvent quand il lui en manque un parce
qu'il le fait par réflexe il va le
chercher au regard sur son doigt et si
là vous regardez il y a un ananas deux
nanana 3 c'est quoi ça lui comme si
c'était marqué là trois nananas aucune
espèce d'intérêt mais juste moi ça m'a
fait mal faut dire on respecte on écoute
on essaie d'avancer pour le pays et je
vais y revenir parce que je veux
comparer au fond de cette réforme mais
on ne peut accepter
ni les faction ni les factions
écouter leurs colères et y répondre
c'est cela parce qu'avec ces propos vous
faites référence au débordement mais que
dites-vous à ceux qui vont manifester
demain 9e journée d'action 11 il reprend
sa position initiale donc il rebloque
les mains pour pas faire n'importe quoi
il y a à la fois de la fatigue dans le
regard on le voit c'est un sourire qui
est complètement simulé celui qui est
pile poil à 41 Loïc sur laquelle j'ai
fait un arrêt sur mage dire que si on
cache le bas du visage qu'on regarde que
les yeux on voit bien qu'il y a pas de
sourire il y a presque du mépris alors
pour pour repérer le mépris sur un
visage c'est quand il y a une asymétrie
quelque part dans le sourire dans les
yeux là il y a quand même une symétrie
on voit bien que il a il a il a joué son
coup il a joué sa balle et là il attend
en retour mais il est pas convaincable
on n'est pas quand même dans une
interview débat on est dans une
interview on peut poser des questions on
accueille une réponse c'est c'est pas un
langage corporel de je suis prêt à une
contradiction à ce moment-là c'est quoi
c'est pas la peine d'y aller il n'y a
plus rien à négocier non d'abord la fin
de partie alors je voudrais essayer de
de dire d'abord ce que ce texte va faire
et pourquoi on l'a fait vous savez au
moment où je vous parle est-ce que vous
pensez que ça me fait plaisir de faire
cette réforme oh la fameuse phrase ça
c'est la fameuse phrase je pense que
tout le monde a retenu est-ce que ça me
fait plaisir de faire cette réforme qui
est quand même un appel au mes émotions
on n'est plus dans le non verbal mais
faire l'appel aux émotions c'est
toujours de la technique de manipulation
si je te demande de venir me déménager
dimanche à 6h du matin et qui me dit non
et que je te feras mais moi je vais
avoir mal au dos et puis avec tout ce
que j'ai fait pour toi tu vois c'est pas
sympa c'est un appel aux émotions là
c'est indirect c'est c'est histoire de
dire est-ce que ça me fait plaisir non
donc si je le fais c'est bien qu'il y a
pas le choix parce que ça me fait pas
plaisir c'est c'est pas de l'argument
mais je m'éloigne je regarde la position
de ces points surtout ces points ils
sont comme ça est-ce que ça me fait
plaisir de faire cette réforme et en
même temps il symbolise l'opposition
forte qui en ce moment entre une major
la majorité du peuple d'un pays et le
gouvernement qu'il représente à ce
moment-là donc ça c'est marrant de voir
ça de voir le cette symbolique de
l'écrasement lorsqu'il balance cette
phrase là il a fait couler tendance ou
qui doit en faire couler j'ai pas encore
regardé les infos aujourd'hui je tourne
la vidéo un petit peu tôt on voit que là
aussi il est bourré de tiques
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas c'est pas un
soulagement c'est pas une forme de
soulagement on pourrait dire mais vous
croyez que ça me fait plaisir c'est
encore une fois quelque chose dans
l'attaque on est plus dans la tête
j'allais dire dans l'agressivité mais là
ce sera abusé mais on est plus encore
dans dans le ring et dans le combat
que vous pensez que j'aurais pas pu
faire comme tente avant moi mettre la
poussière sous le tapis oui
à la Sarko ça me rappelle le moment où
Sarkozy avait eu son entretien très
houleux avec avec Poutine qu'il était
sorti en disant vous avez des questions
posez-moi des questions qu'est-ce que
vous préférez que je réponde aux
questions
alors
y a-t-il des questions oui c'est le même
bruit un peu fatigué faites pas 65 ans
63 ans et demi augmenter la durée on
nous a dit aucune réforme vous n'avez
pas totalement vous n'avez commis aucune
erreur
mais en même temps
je constate qu'il y a aussi une tendance
dans nos démocraties
à vouloir s'abstraire du principe de
réalité et ça
aussi sans doute les conséquences d'une
situation après le covid il a un
contrôle de son visage que je connais
par coeur au fur et à mesure des années
qui est levé le en fait il a un très bon
contrôle de ses sourcils si vous voulez
tout savoir donc on peut pas trop
s'appuyer dessus la bouche un petit peu
moins la se pincement de lèvre qui
reflète une sorte d'agacement sur la
question qui a été posée et de comment
il va reprendre la main il garde aussi
son appui sur notre bras de notre côté
l'appui sur le bras de l'autre côté qui
va en permanence quand il parle à la
journaliste c'est aussi une manière
d'essayer de contrôler les attaques
entre guillemets possible du journalisme
parce qu'ils sont pas non plus très
virulents faut pas exagérer mais c'est
une manière comme ça de gérer un petit
peu son ring de boxe après si je tombais
dans le verbal encore une fois c'est pas
mon rôle mais c'est c'est marrant de
dire de ne pas avoir réussi à convaincre
alors que tout début de la vidéo si je
me suis un bien il parlait que ça avait
suivi tout le processus démocratique etc
et donc que c'était ok il y a quand même
des bouts de dichotomie j'irai voir ce
qui ont fait les analyses les analyses
de des éléments de langage là pour le
coup du verbe
d'un popularité aujourd'hui je
l'embosterai alors voilà pour la
pédagogie l'explication de texte
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe dans la rue
est-ce que vous craignez un embrasement
des mobilisations un pourrissement de la
situation qu'est-ce que vous répondez
aujourd'hui à aux Français qui sont
inquiets aussi de cette situation et
qu'il a subi mais ça a été fait de
manière calme organisée le front de main
c'était normal bon à côté de ça il y a
des blocages il y a des violences les
violences il faut les condamner je l'ai
dignes les factieux ni les factions dans
la République et il y a les blocages et
les blocages et il faut pouvoir les
lever quand ils empêchent l'activité
normale et qui fait avec ses mains
pourquoi je dois passer
j'ai l'impression qu'il va préparer un
petit tour de magie puis regardez de
toute manière avec moi j'ai un lapin
mais il a descendu ses mains qu'est-ce
qui se passe pourquoi j'ai pas un plan
là-dessus il a toujours les jambes
croisées donc il garde le contrôle il a
commencé à rebaisser le visage on le
voit on se treize est-ce qu'il est
embêté par cette question parce que là
clairement sur cette image le
journaliste reprend le lead alors que
quand il a posé la question il avait la
bouche sèche ça s'entendait de ouf lui
il était en stress et Emmanuel Macron la
cache ses mains alors ça peut être un
symbole de moiteur c'est à dire on
descend pour s'essuyer les mains un
petit peu discrètement donc une montée
de stress quand il parle des
manifestants des manifestations du
blocage du pays je veux une GoPro sous
la table la prochaine fois vous pouvez
il y a des blocages
commencent dans nos reportages depuis le
début de la semaine on ne toléra aucun
débordement en France qu'une ville la
plus normale possible puisse reprendre
face à ceux qui bloquent à quelques-uns
l'activité et après
c'est aussi
c'est fou c'est fou parce que quand on
lui demande des solutions alors encore
une fois je m'attache pas au verbal
juste dans le non verbal ça répond non
verbale c'est celle-ci
ça vous rappellera
ça appelle les pleins pouvoirs à la fois
l'honnêteté et à la fois je démontre les
pleins pouvoirs et la pleine puissance
au dessus qui peut régler en fait ce
problème c'est assez marrant de voir ce
réflexe sur cette question-là
spécifiquement
la colère légitime qui n'est pas la
violence encore une fois mais qui s'est
exprimée au moment de ses contestations
alors c'est contestations d'abord
au moment des contestations et elle dit
ah non c'est bon j'en ai pas d'autres
dans quelle situation serions-nous si en
1993 en 2003 en 2010 pour ne citer que
quelques-uns des exemples
précédente en 2013 mais prêts
nécessaires c'était arrêté devant ses
contestations en disant je fais pas la
réforme
on serait dans une situation encore plus
critique bon on est à la moitié j'en
suis à la moitié et il y a des choses
que je pense et voir que je vois pas du
tout je suis assez étonné est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose une mauvaise chose
c'est pas moi qui le déciderai
évidemment on n'a pas de signaux de peur
de la part d'Emmanuel Macron il y a pas
de signaux ultra agressif quand même du
coup je n'arrête même pas à comprendre
trop le mood de cette interview
d'ailleurs je trouve pas qu'en face il a
un répondant bien fort de la part des
deux journalistes pour être très
honnêtes je trouve pas qu'il y ait une
mise sous pression mais lui en tout cas
dans son langage non-verbal je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit venu nous convaincre de
quelque chose en mode ça me prend au
trip j'y crois tellement fort à ma
réforme que je veux absolument vous
convaincre on n'a pas cette excitation
là parce que ça pourrait être ça ça
pourrait être profondément convaincu de
ce qu'on fait et je moi je le vois pas
là dans le langage non verbal il y a pas
non plus de oh là là ça part en
cacahuète soit je j'agresse soit je me
défends avec un peu de pair j'ai pas
tout ça c'est un c'est un mercredi comme
un autre a priori c'est bizarre dans
cette colère et c'est vrai qu'est-ce qui
s'est exprimé
allez on repart à compter Emmanuel
Macron
deuxième chose c'est possible beaucoup
de travailleurs disent vous nous
demandez des efforts il y a des gens qui
travaillent jamais ils ont quasiment la
même vie eux ils vont jamais travailler
ils auront le minimum vieillesse c'est
pour ça qu'il faut très vite engager
avant 14h35 c'est des moments qui sont
relativement illisibles parce qu'il
incarne alors faites pas de Vannes sur
le théâtre d'origine pâqueron c'est
complètement éculé mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que il a cette capacité je
l'ai vu beaucoup de fois le faire il
leur refait là à se mettre dans un
personnage pour faire un tout petit jeu
drôle pour symboliser quelqu'un qui
dirait quelque chose ce qui lui permet
en fait d'incarner à ce moment-là et de
pas être lui dans ce qu'il pense vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
intéressant comme technique pas si c'est
bien mais c'est intéressant et après par
contre quand il a fait sa démonstration
et qui veut convaincre on le voit par
exemple à 14h35 là on a quelque chose de
relativement agressif vous connaissez
quand il y a le visage qui est baissé et
qu'on te regarde dans l'air comme ça et
qu'on ne dit écoute-moi bien écoute-moi
bien maintenant tu vas t'abonner à cette
chaîne YouTube s'il te plaît parce que
si ça se trouve tu es même pas abonné à
ce compte que tu es en train de tu
connais ce truc là tu vois là on le voit
et en fin d'incarnation souvent il a ce
truc de ta compris ou quoi
il y a ce qu'on entend
voilà c'est aussi des protestations sur
le travail vous avez vu le changement
d'intonation quand il a dit à côté de ça
il y a ce qu'on entend dans la rue je
vous parle de la prosodie je suis obligé
de prendre le mot pour pour expliquer ma
pensée ce qu'on attend de la rue c'est
violent c'est fort c'est puissant en ce
moment c'est une colère qu'on ne peut
pas ne pas entendre et bien c'est le
premier moment en 15 16 minutes
d'interview où il va complètement
baisser sa voix à cette hauteur et vous
avez vu ce qu'on entend dans la rue on
ouvre parce qu'il y a un besoin de
justice qu'on entend
c'est aussi des protestations sur le
travail
le dans la rue protestation c'est à la
limite du chuchotement ça c'est une
manière aussi de montrer inconsciemment
comment lui le perçoit c'est jamais des
vérités ce que je dis ne prenez pas ça
pour argent comptant mais c'est une
hypothèse très viable de voici lui
comment il le perçoit donc voici lui
comment il le retranscrit pour moi c'est
c'est le passage le plus important et
intéressant de la vidéo depuis le départ
de la vidéo j'étais pas prêt à ça
j'avais écouté que d'une oreille quand
ça a été diffusé là que je leur regarde
ça me choque de ouf de l'entendre dire
ce qu'on entend dans la rue les
protestations on les chuchote elles
existent assez peu en fait c'est
incroyable c'est du non-verbal aussi la
puissance vocale qu'on va mettre sur un
mois
avec la colère s'exprime pour non vous
fassiez des propositions supplémentaires
on a commencé à faire les choses si
j'étais là à vous dire on a tout bien
fait mais vous êtes un drôle de type
vous entendez pas qu'il y a des gens qui
protestent et ça veut dire par là que
quand ça s'exprime c'est là aussi où une
démocratie elle doit entendre la colère
légitime qui s'exprime dans un cadre
républicain il y a porté une réponse et
donc je dis juste ces réponses qu'on a
commencé à apporter elles ne sont pas
suffisamment fortes et tangibles et donc
on doit aller beaucoup plus loin l'usure
professionnelle les fins de carrière les
reconversions voilà le Move il vient
d'être un peu confronté pour la première
fois par le journaliste vers 17 minutes
et face à cette confrontation il a
ralenti son début de parole il a choisi
ses mots il pose démocratie républicains
des intentions fortes etc ils le
maîtrise à ce moment-là on voit
physiquement il y a des éléments qui
montent qui n'est pas complètement
convaincu de la réponse qui vient
d'apporter qui s'est pas suffisant et il
va en fait complètement bloquer le
journaliste corporellement avec son côté
gauche d'ailleurs il va le bloquer pour
avoir un regard à la journaliste qui l'a
pas confronté à ce moment-là et de temps
en temps il va jeter des regards en mode
je t'ai pas oublié mais tout son corps
va se poser pour empêcher le journaliste
de surenchérir regardez
F et il le contrôle
et ce bras gauche en fait il est en
opposition et maintenant qu'il a repris
le lead il peut se reculer sur son siège
il a remettrisé la situation
le mot smicard il fait quand même
légèrement réagir le visage des deux
journalistes effectivement je suis pas
sûr que ce soit le la meilleure phrase
qui les prononcée
mais derrière ça il y a le sens du
travail
oh la femme de la phrase elle était
comme ça avec un petit recul comme ça du
corps et c'est tout refermer au crocs
et je pense qu'à toi c'est dit je
m'engage à dire quoi là ça va être non
non il a switché et d'ailleurs il a
décroché au regard des journalistes pour
aller bien ailleurs et se reprendre un
fil rouge avec cajouis avec quel
gouvernement avec quelle première
ministre est-ce que Elisabeth borne a
toujours votre confiance oui j'ai nommé
Elisabeth borne
avec un oui on appelle c'est un
pléonasme physique ou de la voix ou de
la tête et par contre il y a un ossement
d'épaule en mode ça fait vraiment oui
j'ai nommé Elisabeth borne regardez
toujours votre confiance oui
Paul ça encore une fois moi je soulève
les trucs que je vois mais mais on peut
faire que des hypothèses derrière on
peut pas savoir le mandat que j'ai en
2017 c'est de créer un système universel
des retraites en aucun cas de bouger
l'âge de départ parce que le rapport du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites et
tous les experts disaient il y a pas de
problème
après cette expression que tout le monde
nous resserre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans notre pays
les gens vivaient dans quel monde on a
eu le covid on a eu la guerre là vous
avez pas besoin de moi pour voir qui se
tape la tête en faisant je vous le
caricature mais ça fait
j'ai compris ce qui se passe ou quoi
côté il y a deux solutions petite 1
c'est fait consciemment et dans ces
cas-là c'est pour ranger l'opinion c'est
tellement évident que vous vous le
saviez je parle évidemment de ceux qui
n'ont pas compris mais on est bien
d'accord quand même et donc tu ranges
les gens de ton côté ou alors c'est fait
inconsciemment et c'est plus fort que
lui qui a bien une chose que je prépare
Emmanuel Macron c'est la bêtise je pense
que c'est quelqu'un de très intelligent
donc quand il fait ça je pense que c'est
réfléchi et calculer dans le bon sens
voilà je suis pas en train de dire que
Emmanuel Macron est super ou qu'il est
pas bien il peut pas laisser ça au
hasard c'est pas possible pas à pas un
geste aussi fort avec les intonations en
plus qui vont derrière ce sont des
intonations de
si tu venais ce qu'il dit alors tu es
obligé de te qualifier d'hommes ou de
femmes un peu stupide en fait donc tu es
obligé d'adhérer à ce et c'est pour ça
que je pense que c'est réfléchi de
d'envoyer ce truc très fort avec les
intonations qui à la fin tu oblige à
dire oui ok ça c'est vrai
l'ordre récolte la santé et l'écologie
un mot plus personnel pour conclure
peut-être monsieur le Président vous
avez été élu en 2017 et puis l'an
dernier en 2022 avec la promesse d'être
en tout cas ça lui donne le sourire en
se pinçant les lèvres de rappeler qu'il
a été élu et que c'est la fin de
l'interview il s'est mis un reset en sa
position de de départ rien n'a bougé si
ce n'est la cravate qui a bougé un petit
peu il y a de la fatigue dans le regard
mais il y a là on le voit bien sur le
scan que je viens de faire il y a une
vraie forme de satisfaction et de je
t'écoute un peu sans écouter vas-y on
conclut en fait bon ben voilà une petite
analyse à l'ancienne pour la fun fax et
Loïc qui m'avait envoyé un texto pour
pour me chauffer à la faire faire la
monter pour la mettre comme d'habitude
ça veut pas dire que j'ai été exhaustif
j'ai scroll certains passages j'ai
essayé de sortir cette vidéo rapidement
juste avant d'aller à mon spectacle de
tourner tout ça en parlant de spectacle
si vous voulez me voir la tournée
toujours en cours jusqu'au mois de juin
de mon nouveau spectacle l'archétype de
modalisme de sciences et de l'humour et
surtout je serai à la Salle Pleyel le 22
novembre 2023 pour une version spéciale
du show donc si vous avez déjà spectacle
ou si vous l'avez jamais vu vraiment
venez voir ça il reste encore la moitié
des places pour le 22 novembre il y a un
nouveau numéro dans le spectacle une
nouvelle mise en scène va y avoir des
écrans géants des trucs très spécifiques
je peux pas encore tous spoil mais ça va
être ouf donc je vous mets des liens
vers tout ça dans la description
abonnez-vous à cette chaîne et puis
samedi une surprise ici aussi sur la
chaîne Youtube vous devriez aimer ça
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao